do you have those shoes in your closet
right now i might let me see yes i
definitely have a shoe storage it's a
problem i don't have that but i do have
a pair of these these are some of my my
faves yes did we just become best
friends i think we just did
[Music]
welcome to full bodied where as the wine
gets darker the questions get deeper we
are here with one of the best basketball
players of all time absolute hall of
famer whenever she retires the style
icon the sneaker god and to me one of
the coolest people i've had the pleasure
of working with sue bird the one the
only we're here at resinous one of my
favorite vineyards top five most
beautiful vineyards in oregon and they
make wines that match the view first of
all cheers thank you for doing this i
wanted to bring this bottle to you
because it is from north folk of long
island
and which is your hood and to be honest
i don't really drink a lot of sevilla
blanc but i like this yeah i would drink
this right it's it's citrusy it's
refreshing it's like if i was by the
pool and it was hot i'd be like all
right right it's easy on the pallet
i'm just curious what is in the water in
long island that made you
as badass as you are i think it's one of
those things like if i had if i had an
exact answer for you i'd be like
bottling it up i'd be putting it in a
bottle i would get a fancy
oxygen thing and i would i would sell it
no i think all the winning is just about
yes you have to be obviously talented
and skilled and all these things to get
to a certain level but i really it's
going to sound so corny but i really
have always put the team's success ahead
of mine
and i found that all the success i could
ever want comes when we win and now i'm
at a place in my career partly because
of my age my experience where i can
really help other people i can really
help my teammates and i can really help
them be their best and then i just ride
them to be honest i'm like take me to
the motherland let's go um so i've been
lucky to have really good teammates
along the way too
you have so many championships and so
many uh olympic gold medals which one
was the one where you were like okay i
have to dig
dig deep it's probably the one that's
freshest is we won in 2018 and it's
definitely seattle because in the wnba
like similar to the nba it's like it's
hard to win in this league like
some of it's luck and the the
competition is so close that in a series
usually the best team wins but like you
never know
so in 2018 this is like probably to be
honest like the best moment of my career
like no joke it for her to happen when i
was 38 is like the crazy part but we
played phoenix in a in the semis it was
a five game series and it was game five
i ended up scoring like 14 or so points
in the final five or six minutes exactly
and it kind of yeah it was like a close
game and it kind of sealed the game
[Applause]
so that was the one where like you talk
about digging deep
yeah there was drama you know it's game
five we've just like you know went to
war with them for four games and now
this is the fifth game diana taurasi has
never lost literally never lost in an
elimination game so it's like all this
stuff is swirling i had broken my nose
the game before there was just like a
lot going on
so that that one that one sticks out
just seeing
the pedigree of basketball that you have
right and the winningest that's i like i
respect winning more than anything else
because i understand how hard it is
we've both seen players and people come
where you go you have everything
everything like you could shoot you
could jump you're smart
and it's just like
their motivation for being great is like
an outboard motor on a big yacht of
talent right yeah the second one it is a
white burgundy and so this is a premier
crew uh which is like higher level of
wine and
to be from burgundy right is to be elite
and to be the best and why it's elite um
is not only where it's from but how they
make it and how they're more hands off
and they allow their wine and the
simplicities of it take over there's
only a few couple of people that can do
burgundy's listen if you want greatness
you got to work for it okay
oh there we go it's the best sound in
the world so while you're pouring that
ooh that was close i would like to know
two things number one who are the top
let's say three to five players you've
ever played against
and then who are your top three to five
players you love watching
okay
cheers cheers
now you taste the difference between the
other one and this one definitely if it
was gross i would tell you yeah please
please tell me if it's gross please tell
me then it's somebody else's fault
best players i played against diana
taurasi for sure okay lauren jackson
brianna stewart i'm definitely biased
those three um are my teammates
so
i had front row seats to the greatness
that the next two i would go
bang so i'm gonna pick guards because
i'm playing against
so every time i got switched in some
capacity on to cheryl swoops
low-key i was like oh
[ __ ]
we cursed
you were like bring that help right you
were like what's up
and then actually the fifth player i
could go lindsay whalen give some love
to another point guard but i'm actually
gonna go cynthia cooper just because
again
she only played in the league when i was
in the league for like 10 games she had
retired and she came back for this one
year it happened to be my second year in
the league and she only got to like i
don't remember exactly 10 15 games but i
was one of we were one of the games that
we played and so it was it was it was
amazing to play against a legend you
know she had started the league raised
the roof that was her thing what about
on the men's side stefan marbury
he was exciting to watch
he was assigned to be a teammate
yeah
jimmer for debt does he count jimmer yes
i mean he's fun to watch because he's
the kind of guy we were like oh this
guy's been dropping 40 in college like
let's see what he's about that kind of
you know we're gonna take a hard left
for okay so
when did you become addicted to sneakers
this is actually an intervention i feel
like the world should know i do have it
under control
i'm acknowledging
the addiction but no i bet it i bet it's
a similar story i'm sure you have a ton
of sneakers just from like being an
athlete
you just get a bunch of stuff i like
literally woke up one day and i was like
oh wow i have a collection but it wasn't
i wasn't like going out of my way to
like stand on the line somewhere
i wasn't hitting my nike rep constantly
it was just like they've done a good job
of getting us the good stuff and now
it's like kind of part of our culture it
wasn't when you think about it it wasn't
especially for a woman it wasn't like
five years ago so i always joke i've
been like waiting for the day
for sneakers to be like appropriate to
wear to like a black tie event i've been
waiting for this day see my kick game
is low-key only good because i was in
the league so long all of nike felt bad
for me and when i moved to portland i
know where they all live so i bug them
shout out tim
and so
you know for me i'm always like hey yeah
oh but they're like chinning damn it i'm
the 18s so there's only so many cool
shoes you can get in the size 18 so you
know i've been kind of hampered where do
you see the kicks i got on right now
could you guess what they are maybe not
so fresh pair of air force ones that
would be my guess
no here watch these boys look
these are a fresh pair of croc air force
ones
hey got the ugg slippers
do you okay listen sometimes you gotta
let the big dogs breathe now look cozy
gotta be cozy what is it about sneakers
that you love and what is it like about
your favorite pair that you love is it
the exclusivity is it the colorway is it
the story what is that so like my
favorite pairs are more the story one of
my all-time favorite pairs and i have
like my originals
right well actually no that's not that's
not entirely true i don't have like the
oog version i have like when it came out
the second time it's since come out like
three and four times um the andre
agassi's they're like yes oh the fast
joints challenges yeah with the pink on
the side i remember getting those in
like elementary school when they came
out again and i could get them as an
adult those are the same ones i still
have and so like those are the ones that
i hold onto tight growing up in arizona
like remember when charles barkley came
out with the cb34s with the first air
bubble my those are my favorite those
are my one of my first and one of my
favorite basketball shoes yes like
obsessed i could not i was crying to my
dad like dad please let me get these
shoes he was like dude so in sixth grade
i was six two wearing like you know how
old are you in six k twelve wearing a
size 13 14 shoe in chuck taylors
but you know chuck's run big right yeah
so like i was wearing a 14
because my dad was like well you're
going to grow into it so imagine
i was getting
roasted yes roasted at school
big clippy cloppy flippers but man it's
just like sneakers are evolving and
they're awesome and they have these
stories but just those original shoes
that you fell in love with are
unreal
so it's funny you say that because my
favorite
by far like all-time favorite basketball
shoe is the original up tempos like
and about
a year ago or so
i was like let me work out in these like
these are some of my favorite shoes like
let me go work out
oh i had to take them off in like 20
minutes i was like these are unwearable
i feel like our our feet are now a
little a little snobby we're very do you
have those shoes in your closet right
now i might let me see yes
i don't know yeah i definitely have a
shoe storage it's a problem yeah well i
got a wine storage so it's a problem too
let me see what i can break out
all right i don't i don't have that but
i do have a pair of these these are some
of my my faves yes i hooped their nose
in my senior year in college this is
before i tell bruh so nobody tell braun
nobody chobron
but i literally
loved playing in those i thought i could
jump it actually helped me get drafted
you know you got to fake it to make it
sometimes yeah there's so many any shoe
with a strap is is perfect any shoe with
a strap is perfect same oh my goodness
do we just become best friends i i think
we just did we can open up these red
bottles now and so why we picked this
obviously ponzi has been around portland
and obviously the willamette valley for
a long time and the winery owners are
women powerful women wonderful awesome
awesome people and so they are just
doing things together where they are
supporting human rights and making sure
that everyone is going to be treated
equally i will say this you have
done so much for not only inside the
wnba and using your platform but just
all walks of life i would consider you a
leader i would consider you one of the
forefront of that um and that is a big
responsibility so how do you
take that how did that come about i have
this like interesting career just
because i've been playing for so long so
when i entered the league the league was
different the world was different
society was different all that stuff oh
yeah so when i first got into the league
and really most of my career like 10
plus years it just we had this vibe of
like be thankful that you can even play
you know don't really push the limits
don't speak on these things it wasn't
that somebody told me not to do it it
was just like a vibe i kind of like
understood what was happening and so i
didn't impressive vibe
i think a combination of things one just
getting older more experienced getting
like more confident in like who you are
a lot of that has to do with um
like when i came out that's a big part
of like saying who you are it just it
gives you this whole other confidence
um so some of it's just like natural
like progression of life some of it is
meeting megan and i think what you see
now is just someone who
feels like i don't regret the early
parts of my career in some ways i don't
know that i was ready there are you know
things that need to be said and i have a
lot of the experience that that i can
like draw on and i just don't want to
miss another moment right like i feel
like i missed a lot of opportunities in
the past so i just don't want to miss
them anymore and that's kind of i think
what you see now from me what is
something that the men can do to uplift
you guys and to like be hand in hand
these are like kind of tough questions i
don't know that i have exact answers i
would say i do think language is
important it's not just how we're
empowering our daughters which we should
it's not just how we're encouraging our
daughters which we should
it's also what we're teaching our sons
because those are going to be the next
generation it's like you have to come
from a place of willing to learn and
willing to like maybe at times um in
that like growth and in that evolution
yeah evolution like in the more
knowledge you gain also kind of
understanding maybe like the privilege
you've had or maybe the things you've
said in the past that weren't
you know on the up and up and just kind
of like acknowledging that not getting
defensive but just like acknowledging it
and then like fixing it and moving on
it's kind of like when you tell a white
person you had privilege
for some reason
it's like this reaction of like no i
worked hard
you know what i mean
yes and it's like
trust me
yeah but it's like yeah you did work
hard i didn't say you didn't work hard
but you had a you have privilege like
you had a head start it's it's a similar
it's it's similar it's not the same i'm
not comparing in that way but like the
like the lesson is similar and then i
think what you said about the media
is so crucial yeah giving women the air
time and not just like showing the
highlight but i hope we get to a point
in our in our storytelling where we're
like acknowledging the story lines in
women's sports and and i think for
women's sports we never tap into those
so people never get invested the way
they are in men's sports it's like a
small part of it but it matters on that
on the youth of the of of the women of
the wnba where do you see it evolving in
the next five years 10 years 20 years
are you gonna be and i'm asking you
personally what is that next goal would
you want to be an owner would you want
to be a coach i don't know that's the
the short answer but
tight it's it's some it's starting to
become a little more clear i do know
that i want to be i'm always going to be
involved in women's sports so i'm sure
you've heard of paige becker's she plays
at connecticut she's a freshman
she's good gracious almighty yeah
insanely good like
you can't deny it the best thing about
her and like her generation so there's a
bunch of players azy fudd's another one
hayley van lift i mentioned caitlyn
clark like they have these followings
right now i'm just saying like you
channing frye former nba player who's
now retired like knows her name
and oh for sure i'm your kid she's a
walking bucket yeah yeah and so people
your kids age or
there's going to be a generation of
people that grow up with paige and so
when they become the 24 5 year old
person who can go out and buy a ticket
who has a family paige is going to be a
household name already like it's
starting earlier so in five years i'm
really excited for where women's
basketball could be because that era of
player they already have a fan base i
had like
the yukon fan base but it wasn't quite
the same she's gonna take that with her
for the next four years and beyond like
i said i don't know exactly how it's
gonna look right but i can't imagine i'm
not involved in some way shape or form
like ownership i think i'd be more
likely to get involved on the ownership
side than i would the coaching side i
feel like coaching's kind of hard
no thank you and i feel like i already
lived this life i don't know if i want
to live it again you know what i mean we
have a game right and this will end on
this okay so since you have nothing else
to do tonight you got to take a sip for
every time you get it wrong okay
here we go right so it's called filling
the grape okay so we have five
categories with a question in each
you're going to choose your categories
and then you have to say the answer so
it's huskies in the w
kicks
history books
wnba assists or megan i'll go huskies in
the w name five uconn players who play
in the western conference brianna
stewart and katie lou samuelson okay
diana taurasi mariah jefferson crystal
dangerfield boom you kicked my butt on
that one history book sounds like a wild
card so i'll take history books can you
name two nba players there's only two
nba players who just like you have won
titles in three different decades i feel
like lebron has to nope
no
nope
tim duncan yeah no he is a big man i
think he went to georgia tech somebody
in my ear tell me he went to georgetown
it was john sally oh john sally the best
damn shorts the best damn sports show
yes
how am i gonna mess that up okay uh
we'll go kicks what sneakers did you
wear when you won your first
championship in 2004 oh the 2k4s
srirachas
i i could have said that everybody was
playing the nose everybody before you
broke the record in 2017
who was the wnba all-time assist leader
oh tisha penetero wow that's so easy
yeah these are easy you guys are lobbing
them in
give me the mega one give me the medic
in 2019 against what team or country did
meghan convert two penalty kicks in
round of 16 to help us secure a win oh
see um
france here we go gotcha take a little
sippy sippy
you could you could phone a friend
ask her see if she remembered i think
she's megan's
maybe sweden okay take one more sip
i don't know germany i have no idea who
they play oh take one more step you
could be lit girl what you do
y'all watching the voice it was spain
yeah yeah yeah oh i told you damn it
yeah i never would have gotten it oh
well thank you for being a leader thank
you for taking the time thank you for
being awesome thank you so much for
having me have a good time another
episode of full bodied this has been
great superb
[Music]